[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we got with us today the cash flow
doctor aka the sound bath expert aaron
oh you gotta bring some next time
sound bath expert yeah so like by day
i'm a financial professional by night
i'm like a sound bath plant medicine
person i like how you balance that's
very bruce wayne of you yeah
that's pretty cool man you use your left
brain in the morning and the right brain
at night that's it that's it the duality
of life my friends a duality of life
dude and also an interpretive dance
connoisseur as well oh yes yeah yeah
connoisseur i have a kind of sword
reflective shades he goes crazy
that's it that's like those things go on
that's it that's that's it that's it
accounting is such
like there's a whole stereotype behind
accountants right and then like it's
like it's just straight up numbers
they're super logical
no emotions whatever and then like here
comes eric
you wouldn't even imagine that this
dude's an accountant you would maybe
think like he's a rave promoter or
something like that right
the way he looks i think he works at edc
and he's gonna try to get us to go there
you know hey did you buy your tickets
yet you know like flyers i got vip
tickets yeah
[ __ ] seats for you bro and they're
like wait what do you really do oh i do
accounting but he does accounting for
like nfts and crypto and all this cool
[ __ ] yeah and he was in very early got a
ton of he's like a resident guru of
everything crypto and nft uh my question
is what happened to tara and why didn't
you save us from it yeah what the hell
youtube we lost everything sound bathing
it happened over the weekend too so i
guarantee you he was [ __ ] sound
bathing all of his friends
i'm just sharing all the good vibes to
try to save everybody they can bring
this down
so
so we're talking about the big gorilla
in the room right tara luna
so effectively
for those of you who may not be aware i
bet everybody's aware of it there's an
immense amount of capital destruction
that happened over the course of 72
hours
it was 40 billion
40 billion dollars billions
being destroyed from the marketplace and
ironically there's 40 billion going to
ukraine too
hmm
[Laughter]
it's destroyed from the marketplace so
they they call this an immense capital
destruction event right so there's an
immense amount of capital that
effectively just got destroyed
and you know money always transferred
from one place to another so people were
making money on shorts basically betting
that the token would go down so it it
went somewhere but there's an immense
amount of wealth that was just being
transferred or being destroyed at this
point in time i heard those suckers only
made three billion so i'm like you
destroyed 40 billion so you could make
three billion you [ __ ] suck-offs it's
about sending a message
i hate you how do i how do i transfer my
poverty now yeah yeah so like poorness
for some additional contacts right this
token or this company or the the the
terra luna token was built by a guy
named dokwan
and so as this is all started rolling
out dokwan is like this charismatic
individual
um which is kind of like you know you
see this in the crypto space a
charismatic individual that had this
underlying technology and a lot of us
we looked at it and said hey this looks
really cool it looked like the future it
looked like the future so there's like
two pieces to it right they had the
stable coin and then they had this
governance token
and so the whole idea is when you're
looking at stable coin many of us use
stable coins because it has a stable
price in general cryptocurrency is very
volatile it goes up and down
so a fundamental part of crypto is
having a stable coin component that a
lot of d fire decentralized finance
operates off of
so the most pop ones right now are like
things like usdc which is from the
coinbase usdt which is from tether and
then we also had the the the one from
tara luna
then a bunch of them get i'll get depend
or something a lot of them so what ended
up happening was
what made tara luna a little bit unique
is they had what they call an
algorithmic stable coin so most stable
coins are pegged or they're they're
linked to an underlying asset
so for example usdc is tied to either
current like other bitcoin or to other
assets so for dollar for dollar you
could always redeem it and then get that
stable coin and that's what causes that
stability in price when they have it
when they like uh like
base it off something
they usually have reserves of that
that's that's the nature of it right and
so this std like tether uh is
it's like a like a south
american currency or something or i
don't know their bank out in like i
forgot the caribbean or some [ __ ] like
that yeah and they're probably based in
the caymans yeah so the tether is a
little bit of an interesting one because
tether
they can artificially print tokens so
there's always a conspiracy theory
happening with tether and tether also
does not disclose where the reserves are
held so we don't know if it's dollar for
dollar
and also part of it is in corporate
assets which are liquid so they could
sell go in and out when you're saying
tether is that usdt or ust usdt
yeah so that's the that's the big like
elephant in the room
so
step like luna and t and um tara they
had an algorithmic one so instead of it
being tied to an underlying asset that
isn't tied to the company the way that
it worked is the governance token was
tied to the the cryptocurrency
and that works really well when the
governance token is worth a lot
right because people have faith and
trust that the the currency here the
stable coins can be good to go
so what ended up happening was for the
last couple of months
um you know the the terra luna ecosystem
was tied to this other protocol called
anchor
and if you know anchor is this protocol
where you can put money in it's like
you're putting money in the bank and the
bank is going to pay 20
and in general terms in the defy world
20 doesn't sound like a lot like there
was a time in back in the day like a
couple months ago where you put things
in like time wonderland or fortress and
all these things and have like
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
interests
nocturnal
you put it in the kfc
damn that's crazy
yeah because 20 is a lot for for the
regular world for the regular world
it's insane
and then so what we're starting to see
and what we're starting to learn as as
things are being unpeeled from this is
the way the anchor protocol is able to
pay such a higher interest rate
was the tara luna foundation was
actually funneling additional cash into
anchor to be able to inflate the
the return on the investment and so what
that was doing is in the ecosystem
people were just pouring more money into
anchor which also stabilized luna and
then also the terror token
those rewards were sweet is that the
part that people criticize as being a
ponzi that's partially that's partially
part of the ponzi right i was going to
say it sounds like it sounds like a
ponzi scheme something take yeah and
i'll miss money
and i'll take some more of the token
over here and so that that was like the
where the ecosystem was and like because
folks were making so much money in this
space we were all very bullish about it
because you know to be honest like part
of crypto world is we're kind of like
degenerate gamblers right so when we see
these gains coming in
life of our increase our return on
investment of these tokens we're like
[ __ ] we're all going to the moon kind of
thing so we're all we ended up being bag
holders
so anyway this whole ecosystem is is
happening
in front of us but there's been warning
signs there's been a lot of analysts
that said hey you know this is kind of
an unsustainable thing you got to be
careful this may not be sustainable
but a lot of us
when you're when you tend to be bag
holders it's kind of like when you're in
an abusive relationship or a religion
you're like nah man ours is the best
kind of thing so they had what they
called the lunatics right the lunatics
are like fans and fanatics of the luna
ecosystem
so what ended up happening was somebody
found a vulnerability in this this whole
ecosystem right and there's a lot of
conspiracies out there some people are
saying it's blackrock or citadel finance
that causes crash and could have been
them maybe but there's no real actual
documentary the only thing we know that
there's been a you can see the
transaction of the short happening
coming from uh what was the one that
they said it came from gemini from
gemini yeah but
that's all they can see is no one knows
who's behind those wallets and because
they act you can see that someone
shorted it right some people also are
suspecting do quan of being shady too
right it's very possible so there's also
there's an alternative timeline
where a lot of the big institutions that
originally invested into terra they're
the first ones to get bailed out
before that the consumers got
basically [ __ ] right
so there's there's a lot of things and
we're going to see this all kind of roll
out like dokuan his assets are being
seized by the south korean government
he's being summoned to
um like an investigation
and people are also realizing now that
he was also a co-founder of a previous
stable coin that failed
that was called balance or i forget
basis cash
right and so people are starting to find
this out now i'm like oh my god what
happened
so this is kind of mechanically what had
happened right
so you have
the stable coin you have the governance
token
and what ended up happening was in order
to keep this ecosystem going do quan
purchased a [ __ ] ton of bitcoin about a
billion dollars of bitcoin to shut up
the haters
that that's exactly it because what what
would happen is
he knew that if the bitcoin maxis
started bitching about his product he
could easily dump bitcoin and cause the
price of bitcoin to go down
right and he did the same thing with
avalanche he purchased a ton of
avalanche
and that's the same thing that we're
seeing right now avalanche has been
depressed very heavily because they had
to liquidate assets to keep this peg
going
so now he's got like all these assets
here
and so what one of the the main
prevailing theories right now is
somebody was like okay how are we going
to do an indirect attack on the bitcoin
um the bitcoin network
and depress the price because we want to
put in a big short well if we could
attack
tara luna
we could indirectly end up attacking
bitcoin right
so what people are speculating and
saying is somebody had a large amount of
bitcoin about billion dollars of bitcoin
redeemed it for the stable coin
and it i know i know it might sound a
little complicated right so i'm going to
try to break it down as simply as
possible they redeemed it for a billion
dollars of the terror stable coin
and now basically lock up a big chunk of
the market
and now this this organization goes back
and says hey we want to sell back the
stable coin
into the market
at the same time like this perfect storm
is happening the crypto markets have
already gone down a little bit because
of inflation fears
because of tightening up of monetary
policy
instability in ukraine and china and all
these different things so that the value
of bitcoin has gone down so the assets
that tara luna has in their foundation
has also gone down because they bought
it higher they bought it at like 40 50
000 and at this time it was already like
30 something thousand yeah and then now
imagine in the marketplace somebody says
hey i need to sell back a billion
of of of your guys stable coin to
prevent the market from collapsing
the tara luna foundation's like [ __ ] we
gotta buy this back and put it back into
the market
but the only way to do is they have to
liquidate their assets that are now
have been reduced in value by 20-30
percent
so now what's happening it creates what
we call the like an algorithmic death
spiral
because they now need to liquidate a
tremendous amount of bitcoin which
further pushes down the price of bitcoin
which also overall impacts the entire
crypto ecosystem pushes the value of the
terra luna token down
and all these things are happening at
the same time
right so this created this death spiral
where now you've seen basically 40
billion dollars of value disappearing
from the ecosystem and the way an
algorithmic stable coin works is
if you have the the the governance token
or the stable coin dollar for dollar
you're supposed to be able to exchange
it one for one
but the problem is when the governance
token goes down in value in order to
continue providing a one to one value
they have to make an issue more of that
governance token
so what you saw within 24 hours the the
supply
or the quantity in the market of that
governance token expanded dramatically
it went from like 2 billion to 17
billion overnight so they have this
rapidly expanding supply of token
and then this stable coin here it's
losing its peg it's losing the assets
that it's backing by and it's creating
this death spiral
so that's why you saw luna go in price
from
effectively like 80 or 100 down to less
than a couple of cents
overnight because you have this number
one that's collapsing in the the crypto
markets
this whole death spa happening where the
price of bitcoins going down depressing
the rest of the market now
the tara luna foundation doesn't have
enough capital to keep raising assets so
they need to keep selling so it creates
this debt spiral now a lot of folks
overnight like there's influencers and
there's people that i know that lost
millions of dollars literally overnight
i'm one of them
i'm sorry sorry sorry
um there's a
famously ksi who's another like yeah
it's paper losses but um at his at one
point no but he kept buying though
that's the thing on the way down he kept
buying on the way down but but paper
losses was 2.8 million
yeah
so you see this massive collapse in
value
and you know some people they've
refinanced their houses because this is
a token that went from
relatively low amounts to a high amount
very heavily it was the best performing
crypto uh in in 2022 yeah and it was the
best performing right it was it was a
top 10 token it was it was the highest
gain yeah
so those there's serious money
you know what's crazy like between me
and my friends i think i think it's a
little shy above
3 million
that was lost
yeah at least between what me and my a
couple of my friends right it was at
least three million lost yeah right
and that's i mean i got away
pretty decent because i i
i thought i de-risked by putting it into
usd a lot of people did a lot of people
thought because it's a staple coin it's
like just turning it into u.s
you know dc us even dollars right they
would they would no one really suspected
a stable coin to dip
like 50 30 even right maybe a couple of
cents like people were laughing possible
i thought the whole point of stable coin
is it's stable
right is that a misnomer though on the
on the name because it's like putting a
lot of faith in in the title of
something and the way that it's coined
that's the new one
eighth coin
that's how like because like i had it
had a decent chunk for me like i don't
have millions in it but i had a decent
chunk of money in it and i was i was
like but i was mostly because like i was
like oh all my friends are doing it
right which is probably not the best
like financially the best way to invest
it's an online roulette yeah that's what
it is but i mean
online crafts like oh you're gonna go in
me too yeah
i wasn't playing with stuff that i
couldn't afford to lose so like
everything that's the key i was like i i
can i can make this back like if i it's
not gonna kill me so i mean
i don't i can't afford to lose a million
bro i don't like
but i did it anyway do you feel good
while you're doing it though i feel like
that's what gets you off though
yeah yeah i mean that's what i mean it's
like that's that's what you're chasing
though you're chasing that next up so
what's your whole experience like how do
you how did you feel the day of how do
you feel now like you must have been
through a roller coaster i like i think
everyone felt the same way where when it
got deep pegged they're like oh this has
happened before um
like it's been to like 98 cents before
but it was corrected in a matter of a
day so then i was telling everybody in
it like if this doesn't correct in one
day we're [ __ ]
and then so
98 went to 97 96
and then that whole day was like wait
what the [ __ ] is going on
and then um you know we all had our most
of our luna staked yeah i had some
de-risk into ust um i had i had actually
a good amount de-risk but then if if if
even if a stable coin
dips like 30 percent dude you know if
you have 100k in there that's 30k just
internet right so like
i got out i was the only one out of i
think all my friends who got out because
they staked everything and there's a 21
day long that's where i was that's where
i was in a state i staked my life it's a
21 day lock so even if on the day you
let go you have to wait a whole month
but we had we had days to get to act you
know so then then not only that like i
don't know i got a bit of survivor's
guilt because while it was going down um
steve was helping me on the phone like
oh you just gotta buy this move it here
whatever uh send it to coo coin whatever
and i was like damn and during the whole
time we were talking
um he de-risked earlier
but then everything else was trapped in
for him so he's out there just watching
his [ __ ] he can't do anything about it
while he's helping me on the phone move
my money out and i'm the only guy out of
our like all of our like uh whale buzz
your family drown but you're helping
someone else
[Laughter]
crazy but your family's so mean though
he sold earlier and took his like
profits and stuff but in this moment no
one saw it coming yeah yeah and then
everyone thought like you know maybe
we'll lose some and then like you know
like you know tomorrow will come and
then it'll pop no one expected it to go
down to like negative
it didn't go to zero it went to [ __ ]
like what the hell was that you know
it went to five zeroes
and i looked at my chart and i'm all
like dude like
for my for just tara alone
i uh i mean my peak was like 1.6 million
but but at this within a week span right
it was about 1.2 million
to absolutely nothing yeah and i was
like wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's like you're watching the chart
because you can kind of see the chart do
this and then all of a sudden it just
like like 90 degree drops
and then what's crazy is when it gets
when it hits the bottom and it can't go
any lower and it just kind of flat lines
at the bottom
in the
yeah it turned into like the heart
monitor and movies
or you're just trying to come on you can
make it back
by the tip
come on but every time every time these
kind of events happen right people kill
themselves people they go through some
[ __ ] right and that's why i have the
survivors guild part because i can i can
play games like this and i know that i
have the earning potential to like go
out there make it again
it's gonna take time like 1.6 mil that's
still a lot of [ __ ] money to me it's
like it's still life-changing money but
this is my second time that i lost such
a big amount last one was in 2018 when i
had a huge dip um but even that i had
faith in recovery because the whole
market dipped i saw you know it was
going from just one hour
during the bear i saw my whole whole
crypto stack go to 10 000 bucks right
but that's just paper wins and losses so
the whole coin didn't destroy so i was
like i'll wait this out
i'll keep buying during the bear and
then during you know the bull it'll come
back again for tara luna i have zero
faith that was just it's just it's just
disappeared the team is [ __ ] dope
though and then if you use the actual
terra like software just the whole
wallet and everything in the exchange it
was so fast it was cheap transactions i
was like this is so good i wish it
worked just because of the interface and
everything you know like
the way that and then we were like able
to like buy stuff you know people were
starting to uh make crypto available for
like travel like a hotel like you could
get a rental car whatever and i was like
dude this is the future it's being used
it's not just a speculative thing now
like there's businesses that are using
this for all these things and i was like
utility was happening and i think that
was the awesome part but i think
for me
um i could sit here and kind of like
joke about it and laugh with everybody
but i know people who are like um their
earning potential is like dude they're
you know they work in warehouses or like
they're they just everyday people so so
they they put a lot into this and then
they made crazy life-changing gains um
it's all relative right because like for
some people like 40 000 is a is a life
or death kind of money and for other
people it's just like oh they could
throw away you know 500 here 500 000
there and they'll make it back
and that's just a game to them and
that's the part of the whole thing that
makes me a little sick because real
people are tied to all this
and then so like when things go bad
i mean we can all say you shouldn't have
[ __ ] you know did that with your
money but like the point is
people do it every time with everything
stocks whatever you know they this
always happens and when a catastrophic
event like that happens
i'm just worried about people's like
mental health they're like like are they
gonna off themselves like like i don't
know you know uh that's the part of it
that's just like oh i wish that wasn't a
part of the game
yeah and it's tough because like a lot
of us our identity and our value is
built upon our perception of money yeah
right bart was talking about that
earlier is reading a book that's talking
about like the psychology of money yeah
and monies right now in our consumer
societies is very important to us
because that's how we determine how
we're worth it to everybody else through
the clothing we wear the cars we drive
the house we have so when people lose a
huge amount of money they feel like you
no longer have value and that's why
people kill themselves right so it's
it's a really
challenging moment and this i think is a
watershed moment for crypto in general
and you're starting to see a lot of like
governmental bodies come out and say
whoa whoa whoa we need to kind of like
look at this a little bit more and
regulate and everything and i know like
the crypto space we're like very
anti-regulation
and it's going to hurt the space for a
little bit but i think long term
this watershed moment although it's
super painful for a lot of us it's going
to be a a positive thing i mean trying
to turn lemons in the lemonade right but
it's going to be a positive thing
because it's going to create live
regulation that's going to create real
stability
right but at the same time too this
regulation is going to take away the 100
x returns that we've seen in the past
but it's going to create stability so
that way every average everyday people
they won't get hurt like this anymore
[ __ ] one percent returns again
dude am i [ __ ] like wells fargo point
one percent ooh
help you save for retirement right right
it's like it's like how do we go back to
that you know yeah i was talking i was
at my barber and he's like oh man you
see what happened to luna man
and then he was like he's a white guy
too yeah
yeah he was like man i saw it dip like
crazy and then i saw two dollars oh [ __ ]
that's a steal so i bought three
thousand dollars
and then he was like and then it's less
than one cent man oh [ __ ]
i you know i did that on the last day
when it was dipping hard i was like oh
this is a good ass deal and i dropped
50k in that [ __ ] oh my god
so i know bro i know dude
i could have got away with more i mean
anybody who bought it when it was five
zeros and a one yeah did you see that
people who bought in there made millions
because they went back up to three zeros
into two
no but they actually it's crazy dude
that weird-ass
you